hi in this video I'm going to solve
another question from I to champ 2016
and this video is on biophysical
principle and so basically match the
column tag questions so we have Group
one and group do we have to match so
Group one consists of techniques and
group two the users of their techniques
so first we have these two hybrid system
it's exclusively used for protein
protein interaction if we want to show
that two proteins are interacting in
vivo I'm sorry if we want to say that
two proteins are interacting in vitro so
it's two hybrid system would be the best
technique then electro phoretic mobility
shift acid also known as MSR gel shift
acid it's a good technique by which we
can prove it have some primitive idea
whether our protein is interacting with
the DNA also it's in vitro process so
it's comes under the in vitro protein DN
interaction then chromatin
immunoprecipitation
or chip chip is very important to find
whether a protein is interacting with
the DNA in vivo in vivo situation so
chip is for in vivo so for in vivo DNA
protein interaction we would use chip
and NMR that means nuclear magnetic
resonance it's for protein structure
determination protein 3d structure so
here goes
NMR so our correct option would be p4 so
here we have two p4 and s 2 we have 2 s
2 and it's a very tricky question
actually so you have another Q 1 and R 3
and here Q 3 and R 1 so we have Q 3 and
R or was 1 so this option is correct
and this option was correct so actually
these type of questions are are getting
a lot more harder these days because
though you can understand the any one of
these two options will be correct but
you have to correctly know what these
two options means otherwise you cannot
guess like the previous years of IRT so
you have to know all these biophysical
principles and all these techniques and
how they
and are the utilities and which feels
they are actually used so if you don't
know is two hybrid system or chip you
can go to my video sections and you can
check in the biophysical principle
playlist I have separate videos on them
hope this helped you please like and
subscribe